what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in and the
foreseeable future
what's going on guys and we are back
with omega-level mutant this week yes we
are and in this video we're going to be
focusing on the character of gambit Remy
LeBeau the occasion sensation from the
x-men yes we are now here's the funny
thing there's actually a little bit of
controversy surrounding his character
and whether or not he should be
considered an omega-level mutant now
it'll become clear what I mean by that
as we get through this video but what we
need to understand first is that gambit
as he's traditionally written in comics
is not an omega-level mutant at least
not any more close but what we're
actually going to see as we get into
this is that while gambit may not be in
omega-level mutant now that the
potential exists for him to become one
or at the very least he was an
omega-level mutant at one time now for
those who are unfamiliar with gambit his
mutant powers are pretty straightforward
he's able to take potential energy
meaning all of the energy stored within
an object and convert that energy to
kinetic energy which is basically the
energy and object generates due to being
in motion and basically make it explode
now one of the other powers one of the
smaller known powers that gambit has is
the ability to stay relevant outside of
the 1990s now most famously gambit will
utilize his power by using a deck of
cards that he'll simply charge using his
abilities and then throw the cards to
produce a powerful explosion which is
really kind of cool now this is
basically the extent of gambits powers
aside from some ancillary abilities like
increased reflexes agility and dexterity
as a result of his control over kinetic
energy but while these abilities
definitely make gambit an elite thief
and a skilled combatant it still does
not even remotely approach omega-level
and so the question becomes why are we
even talking about him in the first
place well as it turns out the version
of gambit that we are most familiar with
is not actually representative of its
full capabilities and the reason for
this goes all the way back to an event
known as the mutant massacre
now the mutant massacre was a crossover
event that saw hundreds of Morlocks
which are basically these things that
have physical deformations and they live
underground in the city of New York but
they were all basically massacred by a
group called the Marauders who were
under the employ of a villain named mr.
sinister one of the other notable events
is that the mutant Massacre actually led
to angel Warren Worthington losing his
wings and then having them replaced and
then becoming Archangel under the employ
of apocalypse as the horsemen death but
for those of you guys who are familiar
with gambit you'll probably realize but
the mutant massacre came out in 1986
which is four years prior to the debut
of gambit in 1990 but all this ties
together is just bear with me for a
second what we learn years later is that
gambit played a critical role in the
mutant massacre story as he was the one
who recruited the Marauders to mister
Sinister's cause now the reason for this
was at around this time gambit had begun
to worry that his powers were growing
beyond his control and so in desperation
he sought out mr. sinister as a way to
prevent this from happening and so mr.
sinister agreed to help gambit by
removing this part of his brain and
thereby keeping his powers at a level he
could control but in return gambit
agreed to assemble the Marauders and
lead them into the Morlock tunnels for
mr. sinister now of course he ended up
bailing out and he was not really
actually part of the massacre but the
fact was he was part of the
organization's side of it but what does
tells us is that for at least part of
the time that we've seen gambit in
Marvel Comics he was not operating at
his maximum power level so that could be
a part of the explanation as to why
gambit is not traditionally considered
to be part of the upper echelon of
mutants in terms of its powers as so the
question becomes this what happens when
gambit is at his full power level well
it's not for the restriction on gambit
powers as a result of his partial
lobotomy would he be powerful enough to
be considered omega-level well funny
enough we actually have a possible
answer that involves the introduction of
a character known as New Sun which is
the variation of gambit from an
alternate universe now what we end up
finding out is that this version of
gambit is vastly more powerful than the
gambit from the main Marvel Universe as
he represents what gambit would be if
you were to reach the full potential of
his powers for those of you guys who are
familiar with the character of cable the
same guy that we're going to see in
Deadpool 2 new son is to gambit what
strife is to cable if you're not
familiar with cable cables and
telepathic and telekinetic
he's pretty powerful strife is basically
cables clone and he's everything cable
could have been stripe is stupidly
overpowered it's ridiculous how powerful
he is there was one point I want to say
it was in Messiah War there was one
point where strife held his own against
apocalypse whoa brain and x-force
Deadpool arc angel and cable all at the
same time it was a lot of craziest
things that I've ever seen
it's the story like the whole thing
itself is mind-blowing stripers he's
such an awesome villains I really hope
we get to see him the Fox is probably
going to screw them up now as for
exactly what new Sons powers are like
gambit he has control over kinetic
energy however new son is able to
manipulate the energy down to a
molecular level what this means is that
where gambit has to come into physical
contact with an object in order to
convert its potential energy into
kinetic energy new son is able to charge
objects from a distance furthermore
unlike gambit new son can use his
ability on living things he can
basically cause people and things to
explode he EE caused objects in motion
to stop four objects at rest to begin
moving at will
he's also able to turn himself into a
wave of pure energy and while he's in
this form new son can travel through
space and into other dimensions and to
get a sense of just how powerful new son
really is in his universe he was able to
defeat the Dark Phoenix which of course
is one of the most formidable forces to
exist in the entire Marvel multiverse
just think about that for second new son
an alternate reality version of gambit
with no limit to his power was able to
face off against a multiversal threat
now what does this mean for gambit in
the mainline Marvel Universe well we do
get somewhat of an answer in gambits
1999 solo series during that story we
saw gambit transported back in time and
trapped in Victorian England while he
was there gambit sought out Nathaniel
Essex the man who would become mr.
sinister and convinces him to restore
the portion of his brain that had
previously been removed during this
series we also learned that new son
inadvertently destroyed everyone on his
home earth and a missed half of his
powers during the performance of a
ritual following this new son would
travel to other universes hoping to
prevent this from happening on the other
Earth's of those universes and so when
he arrived on earth for the main Marvel
Universe New Sun first devised a plan to
create a new planet where everyone would
be transported and enlisted the help of
gambit to do so who we rescued from
Antarctica after the x-men abandoned him
there after learning of his involvement
in the mutant massacre now after
realizing that his plan to transport
everyone on earth to a new planet was
not going to work
New Sun turned his attention to gambit
and hired several assassins to kill him
now all of this culminates a new Sun
taking gambit to his ruin homeworld
using the powers of a mutant called
quiet bill who could open
interdimensional
now on new suns planet he and gambit
began to fight and we end up seeing
gambits full potential completely
realized as he displays powers on par
with others possessed by new Sun in this
story gambit is able to control kinetic
energy at a molecular level fly heal
himself charge objects without touching
them and basically do everything New Sun
was capable of doing now although New
Sun would eventually gain the upper hand
on gambit gambit was able to channel all
of his energy into new Sun causing him
to basically explode and sending
shockwaves throughout the surrounding
area however this battle would not be
the first time that we see gambit
reached the full potential of his powers
but at least up until this point it's
also the last because gambit was forced
to expend so much of his energy battling
new Sun that his power level was
returned to its standard level where
pretty much remained ever since except
for his stint in apocalypses horseman of
death
there was actually a really cool story
that was actually a pretty cool set of
events but with all that in mind
hopefully you can see what I mean when I
said that gambit status as an
omega-level mutant it's somewhat
controversial he's not consistently an
omega-level mutant he's never been
specifically confirmed as being in a
mega level by Marvel which is to say a
signal never scanned him in column a
mega level threat no Marvel riders have
ever referred to him as a mega level but
the power he's displayed in stories
indicates that even if he's not an
omega-level mutant right now he has the
potential to be one I mean if we think
about a for a second part of seeing his
full potential he'd be able to transform
himself into pure energy control energy
at a molecular level and we even saw him
defeat an opponent who was able to
defeat the Dark Phoenix and so for those
reasons I think we can pretty easily
classify gambit at full power anyway as
Omega level while still realizing that
he is most commonly depicted as not even
being close to that character so I'm
curious how you guys view this I'm
curious how it is you guys want to do
this I'll leave it to you guys down in
the description do you guys want to
define gambit as an omega-level mutant
because we've never really done a video
like this before we've not really done a
video where a character displays Omega
level powers but only for a short stint
of time all the characters that we've
covered so far had been depicted as
being Omega level it's because somebody
somewhere in the comic or a writer says
they are storm is a really good example
storm was never an omega-level mutant
until black panther issue number 20
1 or 17 or something like that when it
will refer to her that way it's the
first and only time that's ever happened
but that's all we need to confirm that
storm is an omega-level mutant gambit
doesn't have that no one's ever said it
he's never been identified that way but
this power is universal this is like a
multiversal level of power so it's
insane how capable he is so leave a
comment down below let me know what you
guys think should he be omega-level
should he not be Omega level and leave a
comment let me know who you think it is
that we should cover next preferably I'd
rather it be a DC character I think we
need to kind of switch over to some DC
attention with regards to the beyond
Omega level series or I guess the Omega
slash beyond Omega level series um but
let me know what you guys think down in
the in the comment section and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]